- Okay, here's you.
(bell dings)
Oh, my god.
- Are you kidding?
It's the worst.
- You are 100% talking about me.
- Oh, man.
We're never gonna go to dim sum then.
- Do they Americanize it?
- No, it's just like, when I go-
Like, when I was living in New York
and a bunch of standup
comics would be like,
"Take me to dim sum"
"I wanna go to dim sun."
And then we'd go to dim sun
and they'd be like, "What is that?"
"Ew, what is that? What is that?"
"What is that?"
- Oh, I don't that.
- And they're basically asking,
why is that not a sandwich?
And it's like, you asked
me to take you here.
- I don't do that.
- Also, with dim sum,
it's all pork and shrimp.
Just eat it.
- Yeah.
- Love pork.
- Love-
- Love shrimp.
- Yeah, don't love shrimp.
I'm allergic.
But like, I love pork.
- Yeah.
- That's good.
- I'm not that person.
I will generally try anything.
- As long as you're like, try it.
But it's mostly just all the questions.
- I just thought you were gonna say like,
you know how people are
like, "Oh, I love Chinese."
And then they get like, the
most Americanized basic-
They're like, "I love Indian food."
And it's like, chicken tikka masala.
- [Ali] Right, right.
- It's like the one dish-
- Yeah.
- It's like, that's the thing
that I thought you were gonna say.
- Yes.
- 'Cause that's annoying to me.
And I am one of those annoying people.
- It's more when people are squeamish.
- I'm not squeamish.
- And ask a ton of questions.
- I don't like when
people food shame either.
When they put-
- Yucking your yum.
- Yucking your yum!
Why did you just yuck my food?
Now I gotta eat it.
And you just, you know,
verbally barfed on it.
- Yeah.
- Anyway.
Okay, and there you go.
That was so helpful, America.
You're welcome.
That was Kelly and Ali can't stand it.
Totally.